we're teaming up with IHG hotels and
resorts for today's in a minute and
joining us to share quick tips for
holiday travel this year is travel
expert Lindsay Myers
take it away you're the expert okay so
first of all be flexible we're talking
don't be tied down by dates first I go
to Google Flights I absolutely love this
website you type in where you're leaving
from so let's say New York City then
I'll type in destination Europe you can
search all of Europe at the exact same
time it shows you cities how much they
are so it's giving us the option so you
can really you know do the best trip
ever with saving so much money by just
being flexible with your dates okay and
you Buck accordingly and once you get to
Europe things are so much more
affordable okay everyone okay and I love
the Google flights all right next tip
okay everyone's losing their bags these
days never again no more so air tags
smart tags are your best friend throw it
in your suitcase if you track your bag
at all times on your phone and those are
like 25 bucks there's a range exactly
they have smart tags air tags every
brand has one now but it makes it worry
stress-free travel all right yeah tip
number three stay at IHG hotels and
resorts they have over 6 000
destinations they have 17 amazing Brands
like Kimpton Hotels restaurants
InterContinental Hotels and Resorts we
have Holiday Inn Express we have six
senses we have so much for everyone and
they're really taking care of their
guests and their IHG One Rewards members
this holiday season with Incredible
member discounts I absolutely love it
I'm so excited
Ryan has a hotel no matter where or when
the travel occasion is occurring and
they want to take care of our studio
audience this holiday season so they are
giving each of you 100
000 IHG One Rewards points
um
redeemable
Resort
[Applause]
[Music]